yeah walk him to this video playing
Telamon from the UK this is some the
defense I think with more than one name
it's a very often called to check
defense because it has been developed
mostly bad players from the Czech
Republic um but also sometimes called I
think yes a siren called to the red
Loretta defense it not quite sure why
okay so on I'll plate this 92 this idea
was once shown to me by by a teammate
and I liked it you five or so or d5 was
an interesting way to play let's
consolidate the center
yeah those who is always amazed that it
was very far far reaching decisions are
taking so quickly my most players I
really am NOT the kind of kind of player
who who does that I mean he's just
opening up the position and changing the
pawn structure dramatically I would have
invested a bit a bit of time now night f
46 is a problem the light squares no no
he needs to get rid the bishops again
and let's see the question is is there
g45 already with the direct direct
attack yeah come on let's try that he's
got two pieces for one square
okay so sg5 good now not not clear at
all you take on e5 and then yeah but
still I've got a six even so
he's 695
mmm now I can just take I can just take
it and quince you form y is 6 mmm is six
check at 36 this is good getting getting
the default pond and also have this
dangerous looking past pole so we 70 or
you seven and rook f7 yeah I think I
think I can do that now I'm threatening
Bishop deform amongst others queen dee 5
is also quite quite something
yeah it's just this pony
ok so I don't have hmm methods we see
threatening to take it if I need to play
Queen e6 myself hmm
ok
yeah the question is can he can he take
over you didn't try take on a to him hmm
hmm the check on c4 be three would be
would be excellent okay Adam this is
daydreaming I need to cover the porn
first but how to how to win snapped her
not completely clear maybe I should just
play a queen d for next and exchange
Queens he takes take c5 I got d5 graph
Alfred yeah sure of course not check I
Roxy 7 Roxy 7 I'm such an idiot yeah he
really irritated me a bit with us
frankly speaking idiotic draw phone hmm
yeah there's soon yeah I know I cannot
win him
yeah I can play animals besides Queen d4
and just win this ah what the heck check
I can try to win on time check Gruhn are
oh yeah I'm such a complete idiot what
the heck like Queen deform after the sir
this game looked unbelievable queena for
immediately promotes on fa damn section
[ __ ] Amy okay this is this of course
it's it's it's a win you cannot spoil it
besides playing this crap Queen deform
Queen deform and they simply they simply
cannot move here i mean i can add will
just improve i just not play Queen
deform he cannot he can never move this
because of quincy phone and he has the
moves it's just compass on plus 4 and if
you give it some time it will go up and
up and up and up because so like is
basically without a move and i can just
push forward even this it says you
cannot do anything against that but
queen d 4 is just completely idiotic
yeah I really let this is this silly
draw offer somehow irritated me maybe
but maybe I would have played it anyway
what I saw this of course and this is
completely over and I forgot about that
move simply and now it's just the wrong
just silly
yeah of course the easiest was too and
now here just play this and we book a
phase is over cannot prevent it oh my
what a game thanks for watching